hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game uh from the final
round of the meltwater champions chester
finals is hikaru nakamura versus young
shisht of duda and this game has been
requested a lot even though magnus
already won the entire champions chess
tour uh this is uh uh maybe the last
game we will show from the meltwater
champion chester finals uh and uh okay
i'm gonna go through some other
suggestions but um um
i'm thinking we ended the uh the
coverage with this one and then i have
something very very special planned but
we'll get uh into that a little bit
later so this is hikara vs duda uh
great game you're gonna enjoy it let's
check it out uh hikaru with the white
pieces opens with d4 we have knight to
f6 uh c for g6 knight to f3 and bishop
to g7 going for the king's indian
defense uh also one of hikaru's favorite
openings with e3 uh duda castles and now
bishop to e2 we have d6 and now hikaru
castles we have knight beater d7
preparing to strike in the center with
e5 and hikaru grabs more space on the
queen side with b4 he doesn't waste time
we have e5 and now bishop to b2 so just
both players nicely developing pieces uh
hikaru taunting do that to advance the
pawn all the way to e4 if he dares uh
and yes he dares he he advances it to e4
knight after d2 now he car will of
course
set his pieces up to go after that pawn
uh so rook to e8 do the defense that
knights to c3 adds another attacker and
now knight to f8 uh we have d5 grabbing
more space in the center and now h5 by
duda he might have some ideas of knight
g4 queen to h4 in the future and try and
go for a nice checkmating attack against
hikaru's king queen to c2 adding a third
attacker to the pawn here and bishop to
f5 duda just nicely defends it and now
there is a game where knight the b5 was
played with the idea of shifting the
knight over to d4 uh but here he car
plays rook after e1 and it is now as of
move 13 that we have a completely new
game so let's see how duda continues uh
he plays knight eight to h7 the knight
can now be shifted to g5 or if this net
comes to g4 then this net can come to f6
so many possibilities with the knights
knight to b3 preparing for further queen
side expansion and now knights to g4 as
planned and you don't have to worry
about queen to h for
all that much because you can always
grab the knight here so uh you can
easily remove one of the attackers we
have knights to b5 uh he car also
shifted wants to shift his knight over
to d4 and now a6 just uh chasing it away
uh not knight to d4 right away but first
we're going to capture the bishop bishop
captures on g7 king captures and now
knight 5 to d4 uh queen to h4 now
threatening queen captures an h2
followed by queen to h1 checkmate and we
really don't have anything better than
to eliminate the knight here hikaru
first eliminates the bishop this comes
with check so you have to capture it uh
g captures and only now bishop captures
on g4 we have h captures and now
knights to d4 uh threatening this fork
knight captures on f5 with windu that's
queen so duda boldly goes at f6 king to
f6 sing uh you you got nothing
uh hikaru plays queen to b2 now he's
threatening a lot of very nasty
discoveries uh like uh knights to f3 a
discovery from the queen can pick up the
black queen here but now just rook to e5
and this is a very impressive defensive
setup by duda it's a an attacking slash
defensive setup because obviously he's
the one who's attacking the knight can
come to g5 the rook can come to h8 you
can play queen captures on h2 but also
this rook and e5 uh wha what uh what a
defensive idea uh you can't really
attack the rook again the f3 square is
covered the c6 square is covered so
hikaru starts with king the f1 and this
is in fact the strongest idea you want
to allow do that to capture here
because it could be a little bit
dangerous if the queen opens up the h
file then hikaru can also use the h file
for his rooks but duda again accepts the
challenge queen captures on h2 and now
kink the e2
duda plays f4 now with ideas of playing
f3 so any anything can happen here and
now rook to h1 attacking the queen here
and now the question is why did duda
play f4 how does this queen escape uh
well if we play queen captures on g2
then hikaru just brings the other rook
to g1 and there really isn't anything
for us here we have three check we just
move the king king to d1 everything is
defended you're gonna lose the queen the
queen of course covers the f2 square so
we can't capture that uh uh y just wins
here so duda doesn't uh capture the g
two pawn he just plays f3 check right
away hikaru captures that we have g
captures on f3 with check and now knight
captures an f3 a very sneaky maneuver by
hikaru
this of course now comes with an attack
on this rook there but also attacks the
queen on h2 so e captures an f3 the only
reply and now queen king to d3 and again
where is this queen going you can't
capture g3 and f4 are covered you can't
go anywhere along the h file what can
you do here you can play queen to g2 but
now of course rook ate the g1 so again
what was dude as idea when he started
pushing those pawns how will he
play this out well knight to g5 is what
duda plays and this is uh really really
impressive uh combining all of this with
that
it just seems like uh
uh i i wouldn't say it was pre-prepared
because it seems like too much of an
advantage to give white but who knows
so here the queen has to be captured we
have rook captures on g2 f captures on
g2 now attacking hikaru's rook rook to
g1 and now the beautiful knight f3 now
if the rook moves we can simply bring a
queen into the game because the knight
covers the g1 square so rook captures on
g2 now knights the e1 with check forking
the king and the rook king the d2 and
now knight captures on g2 and it seems
like duda has two rooks and the knight
for a queen which would of course be
completely winning but not quite hikaru
has this f4 move and now he will win the
e5 rook and okay we have rook to e8 and
hikaru now grabs it with f captures rook
captures and e5 duda doesn't want to
mess up his pawn structure and now e4
and now it's a queen against rook and
knight
in a completely crazy position it's a
rapid game so
uh not a lot of time can be spent
analyzing the move so king to g6 and now
queen to a3 now with ideas of just
delivering check here or maybe even
queen f3 going after after some pawns if
the king moves so knight's the h4 now we
don't want to allow any any tricks here
and queen to g3 with king h5 we have to
defend our knight king to d3 now uh we
have b5 uh you have to create some
weaknesses here in the white spawn
structure and now queen to g8 uh going
after df7 pawn we have b captures on c4
with check king to c3 now if you go king
to d4 or you capture on c or if capture
on c4 then dudeo can just capture an e4
if you go king d4 then f5 can be
somewhat annoying if you capture knight
can capture here if you don't then rook
captures here so maybe not the way to go
but okay after b captures and c4 uh with
check king the c3 is played and now only
now we have f5 uh advancing the spawn
now uh a duda will either get a pass
pawn or a hikaru has to capture on f5 so
e captures an f5 knight captures on f5
and now we have queen to h7 with check
still waiting with the capture on c4
king to g4 now comes queen captures on
c7 so grabbing that pawn instead
but now
there are a lot of pieces around the
white king so here knight the e3
defending the pawn and now maybe hikaru
is thinking okay maybe i should have
eliminated this pawn could be somewhat
of a nuisance also dude is just
threatening knight captures on the e5
which would lose the queen so queen to
a7 uh now uh with the idea that the
fruit captures then you lose the knight
and if the knight captures well then uh
the c4 pawn is no longer defending we
can just capture that so queen to a7 a
good move by hikaru king the f4 duda
brings his king closer to the action and
now we have not queen captures on a6 but
rather we have uh
uh sorry uh we have a4
uh so what do you play here uh well rook
captures on d5 now it can be played as
the knight is defended and now queen to
f7 with check king to e4 and now queen
to e8 check king of three and now b5 so
with the attempt of creating a pass pawn
a captures on b5 a captures on b5 and
now rook to d3 with check king b4 rook
to b3 with check now kink the a4 keeping
an eye on the pawn here also you can
start pushing the b the c pawn because
the rook would fall on b3 so d5 we
advance the other pawn and now queen to
c6 preventing this pawn from being
pushed due to the pin king the e2
unpinning and now queen to h6
uh so what do you do here uh d4 duda
just continues advancing his pass pawn
queen to h to check now uh so what you
play here king to d3 and now queen to g1
here the safe uh safe move for hikaru
would be some like queen to d6 just
prepare to further advance the pawn uh
but he goes for queen to g1 and now what
can do that play will rook to b2 uh now
you can uh
block block some checks you can attack
the queen you can do many things here
with the rook but also uh you are just
having a rook behind the pass pawn it's
always great whether it's your own pass
pawn or your opponent's pass pawn so
queen to g6 check king to d2 and now
queen to g7 putting pressure on this
pawn so king to c3 by do that we have
king to a5 and now comes rook to a2 with
check king to b6 now comes rook to f2
yeah at rook to f2
it was what was played in the game rook
to g2 makes a a little bit more sense as
it forces the queen to move away and
maybe even from this diagonal but okay
rook to f2 was played like i said this
is a rapid game king to c6 now making
room for the past pawn to be pushed and
now king to d3 now you of course on pin
and now you are ready to start pushing
your pawn and even though white is
faster in pushing the pawn uh black
spawn queens and c1 the same file that
the king occupies so black queens with
check
also something to keep in mind queen to
h7 check rook to f5 again nicely
blocking these checks b6 with c3 b7 c2
and now b8 queen and uh duda also plays
c1 queen so now the three queens are on
the board and this is extremely
complicated um uh one queen and several
pieces is not as complicated as two
queens two queens are so complicated
because even though it's like yeah okay
one queen and then you have two queens
it it's not twice as complicated it's
much much more complicated so here we
have king the d7 escaping check and now
queen to a3 so really trying to create
some sort of a meeting mating web
against hikaru's king
but there are two queens here so queen
to b5 with check
and now
there is a winning idea here i'm gonna
show it i'm not gonna ask you to pause
the video or anything because it's uh
it's a rapid game plus it's a very very
difficult to spot uh but here as there
are two queens on the board uh here king
to d2 was played but the winning move is
king to c3 this is something uh duda
missed uh
but it's very very complicated the thing
is after queen to c6 check you can block
with the rook and now there are no more
useful checks
uh it's just a very lovely setup here
that the white really can't uh
penetrate if queen to b7 we're going to
deliver rook d5 check this king eight if
sorry if um king k8 we're going to
deliver rook to e5 check and i have king
f7 now we can bring queen to c5 and we
have this amazing structure here that
white cannot penetrate we're going to
start by bringing our knight into the
game and slowly but surely we're going
to win the game regardless of white
having two queens but he did uh didn't
go for uh king to c3 he played king to
d2 and now he allows nakamura to just
draw the game yes draw the game even
though it's two queens um there's no
winning this because there are simply uh
too many pieces around the white king so
you have to go for queen to h to check
and then go for some sort of a perpetual
here as the white queen also covers the
d3 square
but he played queen to b6 and now uh
well now many things are winning for
duda uh and he plays uh one just such
thing he plays queen to a4 with check
and now it doesn't matter where you go
if you go king e7 knights to d5 fork
just wins the game for example king e6
we can even play rook f6 checking
captures rook captures uh we're up a
whole rook of course completely winning
uh so instead after queen at a for czech
king that e6 was played but it's not
much different queen to e8 with check
queen to e7 and now i'm sure you guys uh
can
figure out what was played here it's
very very simple
uh so again i'm not going to ask you to
pause the video
but it's queen captures on e7 this is
what duda played and he was in this
position on move 69
that hikaru nakamura resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh so the thing is you're in check you
have no squares with the king your only
move is to capture the queen but now
this fork comes and then after king to
e6 knight captures and b6 king captures
an f5 we get this end game where black
is of course completely winning he has a
past pawn uh
uh sorry uh past pawn uh and a knight so
you're not gonna be able to uh block
this or anything uh so a very very nice
victory uh by duda hikaru found the
winning idea very early on and his king
move was incredibly impressive here when
he when he played it here in this
position let me just quickly rewind or
rewind yeah uh here because duda can
simply play this knight g5 put pressure
here but hikaru just said yeah capture
the pawn i can move my king i can use
the h and g squares
h file and g file for my rooks and he
calculated everything perfectly
but for some reason
it didn't work out the two queens are
simply too complicated
uh so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
dude i won only this game the other
three were won by hikaru so hikaru won
their direct match but i thought you
guys would enjoy this one because it's
just complete madness on the board and i
know how much you guys enjoy uh games
like that uh so i also mentioned that um
i i'm starting a new uh
uh series it's gonna be the the greatest
uh chess games ever that you've never
heard of and they're really really
impressive uh so stay tuned for that uh
and yeah i hope you guys enjoyed that
and this short coverage of this very
nice tournament uh i would like to thank
michael kennedy and constantinos from
pedakis ricardo rodriguez ryan urban and
nima mosseni for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon uh
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh checking up on uh
everything else that's happening in the
chess world uh and you know just doing
uh what we usually do here uh so yeah
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day